hey guys it's a lot today I'm going to
be talking about something that has
bothered me for a while so anyone who
has read the comments section of a
review on any major website firstly I'm
sorry you should know better but
secondly you probably will have seen at
some point someone saying you are too
biased or this review is not objective
or this is just your personal opinion
the first of all it's literally
impossible for a human being to
interpret entertainment media
objectively I say this not only as an
opinionated nobody but also as an X
psychology student and a current
entertainment student student and people
are entertained by things in different
ways as a result of this this is
creating a personal bias that may not
even be happening on purpose that can't
be avoided it's also impossible to know
how every single reader would experience
again because once again people are
entertained by different things because
people are different the only way that
you could really review a game even
close to objectively would be if you
were just listing specs actually a
Wikipedia page is basically an objective
review of the game just a list of things
that happen with absolutely no opinion
on whether those are good or bad
objective there on the other hand there
are some people who are far too
subjective an example of this would be
someone saying they didn't like the
latest call of duty because it was a
shooter that is whole other thing and
the weird part is the people usually
commenting you're so biased why don't
you like this game are usually just
saying that because of their own
personal bias I like high my personal
bias is different to yours therefore
you're too biased it's just that
entertainment itself is a subjective
thing you can't be entertained
objectively so point number two is that
it's actually a very good thing I have a
lot to say about this one it's super
entertaining every single person
reviewed games objectively once again I
say like a Wikipedia page this game has
this it does this this is the plot flash
2 comments
that objectively sounds like a video
game huh I see it has gameplay we don't
we talk about that but most importantly
it generates discussion so when I say
that I have problems with the bioshock
infinite or assassin's creed and other
people commenting agreeing for different
reasons or disagreeing for different
reasons we are creating a discussion
about something and the big bad
publishers want to sell us things right
that's what they're there for I doubt
that the CEOs of these companies care
that much about making these amazing
experiences anymore they just want to
sell you stuff so if nobody ever
complains and if we don't have differing
opinions they're just going to make the
same generic trash over and over and
over again if nobody ever complains
about a game or criticizes a game then
games aren't going to get anywhere
they're just gonna be the same so the
publishers are like jump well done
ladies and gentlemen that's so extremely
well and nobody complained about
anything so let's just double the
marketing budget and make even more
money next time without changing it
thing which I don't know for the future
of gaming seems kind of like a bad thing
so without subjective opinions from a
variety of people with different
backgrounds or different perspectives
that come from different experiences
games are probably just going to be made
for the same people on that same token
and for my last point I promise
criticising something doesn't mean you
hate it if someone disagrees with you
you don't have to be like screw you you
are incorrect this game it is perfect
way to everyone keeps saying bad things
about it you should be like I disagree
but I respect that you are taking the
time to share that because it is
actually productive so I guess you know
what keep complaining about things that
you love keep being subjective and keep
giving your personal thoughts because
that's how we make change we don't
change things by saying exactly what we
think everyone else thinks we should say
we don't make any difference to the
world by doing exactly what other people
think we should do and when you see
someone who disagrees with you feel free
to disagree back but you don't have to
be a jerk
about perceptions man and now I'm kind
of exhausted after that rent oh I'm
looking forward to the comments that
tell me that I'm wrong but I guess
that's it for this you guys I'll see
y'all next time bye bye